[Music]
good morning everyone welcome to this
virtual stage where i'll be taking you
on a
behind-the-scenes tour of black holes
i'm dr emily santosh i normally
lecture at university college london
but today my role is to serve as a kind
of guide
to show you some of the science
behind black holes as well as some of
uh the technology i think when it comes
to black holes i
personally cannot make my mind up
whether what i find most fascinating is
whether
the fact that these things even exist
right that there are such thing as black
holes out there in space
or the fact that we have been able to
build some incredibly complex machines
and develop some mind-blowing theories
to be able to comprehend black holes and
find evidence for them so
i will present you both of these things
and i will let you be the judge of you
know what you think is the most
fascinating part of this
uh black hole story so to get us
started i've put a an image here of
a supermassive black hole not a real one
one for the movies
um if you have seen you will recognize
this as the supermassive black hole
that's a key uh
protagonist in the movie interstellar
and i feel confident showing you this
because this is a
the amount of work and care that has
gone in producing this image for the
movie is actually so good that it
is a scientifically accurate uh
representation of a supermassive black
hole
until about a year ago that's all i had
at my disposal if i were to talk about
black holes i couldn't show anybody an
actual image of black hole but that
changed drastically about a year ago
when we finally got the first image of a
supermassive black hole
now remember when that came out at first
in the news there was a you know
reactions from the public saying oh well
that image it's a bit rubbish doesn't it
i can't see anything it's all a bit
blurry um whereas for us as scientists
it was just
an absolute uh revelation and hopefully
you know
by the end of the talk you'll appreciate
uh just how amazing this image is
especially if you're in that camp of
being slightly underwhelmed when you
might first have seen it
so before we go into any of that just so
we know because 101 just some basic
facts about it so what is a black hole
well black hole a black hole is you know
in some sense a mathematical construct
so black holes really
took off um beginning of the 20th
century when einstein wrote down
the equations for general relativity and
from that point there was you know
almost an arms race to just solving that
equation so final
sign providing with the framework and
then all sorts of different physicists
try to solve the equation to find
all sorts of things about you know the
universe and one of those solutions that
you find to the equation is something
that is a black hole so a mathematical
singularity meaning a single point where
the curvature of space-time caused by
general relativity becomes infinite
in other words it's a point in space
where all the mass
is located in an infinitely small volume
meaning you get something with an
infinite density
it's almost a mathematical impossibility
something you can describe with an
equation but if you think about it in
terms of physical
terms it makes no sense how can
something have infinite
density yeah this is what you know a
black hole is
based on these equations so for a long
time the black holes were seen just as a
quirky
mathematical construct yes it's a
solution of these equations but
it cannot be no it's it's it's not but
as i'll show you now we have clear
evidence that these things are true
so when you think about the black holes
and the singularity that is that point
of infinite density that is the black
hole itself
but often when we think about the black
hole we think of it as having a radius
of finite size and that was we call the
event horizon
the event horizon is the closest
anything can get
to a black hole and ever escape right so
even
light who travels at the fastest speeds
we think anything can
reach in the universe if it crosses
within the event horizon it's done it
cannot never go out gravity is so strong
it will pull it in towards the
singularity
what's really interesting however is
that there's nothing special about the
event horizon
if we were you know an astronaut somehow
had managed to
go there and see it we would cross the
event horizon
and nothing notice absolutely nothing
there's nothing special about the event
horizon and that's a fundamental thing
that general relativity requires that
there's nothing special about the event
horizon
other than the fact that you know once
you cross it there's no coming out but
you wouldn't know that
if you were at that point um so i've put
these three words at the bottom left
corner mass spin in charge and that's to
highlight a fundamental uh quirk and
something quite interesting about black
holes
so people came up with something they
called the no hair
theorem um it was coined as
you know black holes are so featureless
that it's like a bald head with no hair
and
don't ask me more why it's called like
that but it basically says that black
holes can be uniquely described by
three numbers only their mass that's
quite clear
the spin which is the word we use to min
the
speed at which something is rotating and
the charge which is
electric charge whether it's positive or
negatively charged
and that what the theory says is that
you can uniquely describe a black hole
based on only these three numbers
and that that is really really unusual
right if i take
um something i have my phone here and
then i have this mug
right um they both have the same mass
roughly
i can make them spin at the same rate um
neither have an electric charger i could
pretend they have the same electric
charge
but clearly you everybody can see that
you know that's a phone that's a
that's a mug they're not the same and
the reason is that to describe them we
would need
a lot more numbers than just these three
numbers right we need something to
describe what they're made of
their shape and so on and so on
so it's quite strange that black holes
are so simple
right and that leads to
fundamental problems
my major crisis in modern physics right
so you've probably heard how in physics
we have these two massive pillars right
we have general relativity that
describes the science of the infinitely
large
space everything like that and then we
have quantum mechanics
that delves into the infinitely small
things at
you know atomic levels and these two
theories are in themselves
wonderful they explain you know most
everything we
know about the universe the problem is
that
we do not have a language for both of
them to communicate easily and to form
one
single physical theory and there's
almost nowhere where that's most
obvious than when thinking about black
holes
so quantum physics has something they
like
they have you know you've heard about
conservation of energy
these kinds of principles where energy
is not created or destroyed there's a
similar thing in quantum physics that's
called the conservation of information
whereas information can never be
destroyed
so um for example if that's
the problem with this with the black
holes like again if i go back to my
example here
um if i were to you know send my phone
my phone were to fall into a black hole
the map the black hole would grow in
mass by the equivalent mass of my phone
and if i were to throw my mug in it
would grow in mass by
the equivalent amount of mass
so that mean as an outside observer when
i look at the black hole i would say
okay the black hole has
grown by this much mass but i couldn't
tell if it's because it
has absorbed a phone or a mug or you
know anything more realistic in outer
space
so information all these extra numbers i
needed to describe
these two things have been lost right
they've been lost when they go into the
black hole
and that's a huge issue for quantum
mechanics because information has been
lost
there's all sorts of ways to reconcile
this paradox
but no matter how we do it at the moment
you have to give up on some of the
fundamental principles of general
relativity or quantum mechanics
so i won't go any further in this that's
a super interesting uh topic
but for now let me talk to you about the
astrophysics of black hole what we know
about them
so there's a black holes have the basic
or not
all that mysterious there's an easy way
to form them
right so when stars are born
they you have stars of different masses
small stars and big stars
and then they spend most of their
lifetimes just
doing nuclear fusion turning hydrogen
into helium and so on at their course
and when they run out of fuel at that
point there is no more
internal pressure to support the
enormous mass of the star so the star
starts to collapse on itself and for
stars that are very massive
there is so much mass that wants to
collapse in itself and nothing to stop
it
from collapsing that it will collapse to
the point of the singularity
that point of infinite density so we
know quite well how to form
you know what we call a solar mass black
hole so you take something that has the
same mass
as the sun which you see here just for
reference no this is the earth down here
to scale
and then if we were to compress the sun
down into a black hole its event horizon
would be
about this big you know a few kilometers
across i put it on the map of london
here for
reference it fits well within the m25
well within central london
so it's crazy amount of mass in a very
small amount of space
so we have these small stellar mass
black holes we know how to form them
they're just a natural end product of
the lifetime of a star
the question is how can we then convert
these into the supermassive black holes
that we observe at the center of most
galaxies
well one easy way to do it which is okay
you start with a small black hole
and you have it eat you feed it with gas
and stars and all sorts of things like
that and you let it grow until it
becomes
you know a monster millions of times the
mass of the sun
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai dot tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas
you